-Welcome, everybody.
Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show."
You're here. You made it.
Thank you for watching at home.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, guys, we are right in the
middle of the holiday season,
and I saw that Instacart
is now offering
same-day delivery
for Christmas trees.
So remember to tip,
because your delivery guy
definitely has an ax.
Yeah, wow.
Of course, it's Instacart, so
get ready for a text that says,
"They're out of Christmas trees.
Is Pepsi okay?"
And you go, "Pepsi?
That's not even --"
Yep, Christmas trees
on Instacart.
It's a beautiful
new family tradition
of gathering around papa
until he swipes right
on the perfect balsam fir.
"Dad's getting his phone out.
Come on, let's gather up."
I don't want someone else
picking out my Christmas tree.
I don't even like someone else
picking out my cantaloupe.
I was like, "Oh,
you thought that was ripe?
Didn't you knock on it?"
Is that what you do with
a cantaloupe?
Do you knock on it?
-You got to thwap the end.
You smell it. You know.
-Certain things I just knock on
and think I know
what I'm talking about.
Do you knock on a pineapple?
That does nothing.
You peel the leaf of
a pineapple.
-You pull the leaf.
-Watermelon I knock on,
of course.
That goes without saying.
-Knock on wood.
-I knock on watermelons
I don't even buy.
I just go up and go,
"Hey, what's up?"
-Fill it with vodka.
-Yeah, yeah.
Did you guys see this?
New York just passed a law that
makes all gift cards
purchased in the state
valid for at least nine years.
-Ooh!
-You know you got someone
the perfect gift card
when it takes them 8 1/2 years
to use it.
"Well, you like
Home Depot, so..."
8 1/2 -- Yeah.
They're good for nine years,
although I'm not quite sure
what to do with a valid gift
card from Borders Bookstore.
What am I doing?
Find me a Borders.
Let's get to some news.
Due to a rise in
COVID, RSV, and flu cases,
New York City health officials
issued an advisory
urging people to wear masks
again.
I think they're getting
tired of these announcements,
'cause this one felt a little
more casual than the rest.
Take a look at this.
That's...
-Wow.
-That was fast.
♪♪
That's it?
That was fast.
That's right -- New York City
is experiencing
high levels of
COVID, flu, and RSV,
and health officials are
calling it a "tridemic."
-Aw, come on, man.
We can do better than that.
-What's that, Tariq?
-I said we can come up with
a better name than a "tridemic."
That's so clunky.
-Yeah, you're right.
"Tridemic" doesn't even
rhyme with anything.
What are you thinking?
-Um, the three-sles.
-That's good.
Scarlet three-ver.
-Hepa-thri-tis.
-Gono-three-a.
-The thrice-capades.
-The thrice is right.
-Trip-slip.
-Fuzzy triple.
-Mm...
uh, "Three Strains and a Baby."
-"Three Strains and a Rabies."
-[ Laughs ]
-Once, twice, three
types of achy.
-The Tri Guys.
-We can just call it
"Three's Company."
-How about "All I Want for
Christmas is Achoo"?
-Rocking around
a Christmas three.
-Oh. The tres race.
-Ooh! The tres force.
-Left without a tres.
-All aboard the flu-flu strain
choo-choo train.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's it.
That's the one. That's it.
Tariq Trotter got it right.
[ Dinging ]
That's it, buddy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Well, guys,
Elon Musk is still on his
"trying to make
people upset" tour.
And Elon is being slammed
for a tweet
he posted yesterday that said...
Fauci was like, "Yep,
much like a Tesla battery,
Elon's on fire."
Yeah. You could tell Fauci
wasn't having it
because he wrote back,
"Congrats on making Twitter
the Johnson & Johnson vaccine
of social media."
Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Meanwhile, Elon also said that
Twitter's character limit
for tweets is going to increase
from 280 to 4,000.
People are like,
"4,000 characters?
At that point, I may as well get
my news from the news."
Switching gears,
King Charles just released
the first royal
Christmas card of his reign.
Ready for it? Here it is.
"Wishing you a very happy
Christmas and New Year."
It has the same
emotional feeling
as a holiday card
from your dentist.
"I can see through this."
Seriously, the love and emotion
just flows from that guy's pen.
Are there budget cuts
at Buckingham Palace?
Is that --
Is Elon firing everyone
in the card division over there?
Well, here's some big news.
The other day, a lot of people
were surprised to
see Ben Affleck getting coffee
at Starbucks.
-Oh!
-Ben Affleck was
drinking Starbucks,
and it didn't take long for
Dunkin' to respond.
Watch this.
-Well, well.
You think you're better than us,
Benedict Affleck?
You think you're wicked smart
going to Starbucks,
sipping $6 drinks like
the freaking King of England.
Enjoy your foam in a dome,
you L.A. jabron.
Just go ahead and go.
Tom Brady left us,
and we're fine.
We still got Matt Damon
and a half-dozen Wahlbergs.
We'll bounce back,
even if we feel the way
Bill Belichick looks.
-Oh! That's so sad. Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Moving.
-No, you know ben.
This is Dunkin'.
He's Dunkin' all the way.
-Yeah, come on.
-And, finally, we have
exactly five shows left
before we go on Christmas break,
which means it's time for
that beloved
"Tonight Show" tradition.
It's time for "12 Days of
Christmas Sweaters."
-♪ 12 Days of
Christmas Sweaters ♪
♪ Five days left ♪
-That's right -- every show
between now and Christmas,
we'll be giving
one lucky audience member
an mm-mm-mm Christmas sweater
from the "Countdown to
Christmas Cabinet."
Since there are five shows left,
let's open door number 5.
Where do we go?
-Right here.
-Alright, go for it, bud.
Whenever you're ready.
Oh, my gosh!
Wow! I don't know what that is.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Is that a sweater?
[ Cheers and applause ]
I don't know what the heck --
-Turn it around?
-Yeah.
That's the back of it there.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
-Wow.
Alright. Wow!
-Oh, my gosh. This is heavy.
Alright, now let's see who's
going home -- Wow!
This is 100 pounds.
Let's see who's going home
with tonight's sweater.
Everyone look at your
seat number, okay?
If I call your number,
come on down.
Quest, can I get
a drumroll, please?
[ Drumroll ]
Who wants this sweater?
This is a...
[ Cheers and applause ]
314!
♪♪
Come on down.
Come on!
It's getting heavy.
Hey, come on,
we got a show to do.
Come on, get over here.
Here, go on over there.
Gosh, this sweater's heavy.
You take your time
with that one.
Gosh. Welcome.
-Oh, sorry.
-Thank you for coming.
Thank you for being here.
What is your name?
-Marcella.
-Marcella, where are you from?
-California.
-Hey!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Marcella, this is perfect
for California.
-Yeah.
-Everyone in L.A.
will be wearing these.
Do you have anything
like this at home?
-Nope.
-Oh! Nothing even close?
-Uh, no.
-Yeah.
Marcella, would you try this
on for us tonight?
-Yeah.
-Alright, cool.
Roots, can I get some music?
♪♪
We need some help here.
Alright, good luck.
I feel your head.
I feel your head in there.
Okay, good.
Marcel-- Oh! Can you breathe?
-Yeah.
-Yes, you're good. Alright.
Sorry.
-I'm, like, nervous.
-No, that's alright.
Oh, yeah, good, Marcella.
Yeah, gorgeous.
-Oh!
-No, this is perfect.
Marcella, turn around.
This is good.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, my gosh.
That is unbelievably gorgeous.
Beautiful.
Thank you so much, Marcella.
Congratulations.
Thank you very much.
-I just had an
ugly Christmas sweater, um...
-You just had an
ugly Christmas sweater party?
-Party.
-Yeah.
-And it's too late.
-Yeah, too late now.
But you got to go back.
But you have this to go to
the next one.
Have another party next week.
Thank you very much.
Congratulations. Thank you.
Good job!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Can I have a hug?
-Yeah, of course.
-Thank you.
-Fur and glitter and everything.
Well done, pal.
You rocked that out.
Guys, you know what?
I'm not done.
[ Cheers and applause ]
How come only one person
gets to win something, huh?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let's take this
to the next level!
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's time for "Tonight Show
Stocking Stuffers"!
Here we go!
♪ It's "The Tonight Show" ♪
-♪ Stocking stuffers ♪
-Now, there is no need to check
under your seats for this one.
Every night
until Christmas break,
we're giving away
an awesome gift
to every single person
in our studio audience.
You guys excited?
You guys ready?
[ Cheers and applause ]
You guys want to see what you're
going to take home tonight?
Quest, can I get
a drumroll, please?
[ Drumroll ]
Tonight's stocking stuffer is...
a Nintendo Switch,
OLED-model system,
"Splatoon 3" game,
and a 3-month subscription to
Nintendo Switch online.
-That's right, Jimmy.
This holiday, splat the halls
with "Splatoon 3,"
the new game from Nintendo
where you compete with friends
and splash the most ink.
Play on your TV
or handheld or tabletop
with the Nintendo Switch
OLED mode.
Who knows?
You may even get
splatted by Jimmy
when he's playing online,
via Nintendo Switch online,
which means you'll all get,
for free for three months,
so much fun.
Jimmy?
-Thank you!
Thank you to our friends
at Nintendo.
Enjoy your gift, guys.
We'll be right back with
Kate Hudson!
Congratulations!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪